i say this with all honesty and
sincerity the fact that i can have this
man call into the show
um to talk about uh the passing of one
of his great friends and
one of his friends and one of his
colleagues the fact that i have the
ability to do that for me
if you had told me back when i was
watching him uh
on the nfl today on cbs i'd say you
could knock me over with a feather it is
an honor as always to welcome brent
mussberger to the program how are you
brent
sad uh moment yesterday when i i heard
of the
passing of of our cross i i have to say
that he might have been one of the
nicest
people that i've ever been around and um
i never heard
him say an angry word about another
person
a nasty comment and i and i never heard
anybody say anything negative about irv
he was uh he was a special gentleman
and uh you know goodness with the egos
that i had on the show with the greek
and
a former miss america and phyllis george
and mine was growing
uh to a single level it was it was so
nice
uh having the steady hand of our cross
what was it like in 1975 putting a show
together
uh with somebody you know who you did
know from back in the day
but irv was essentially bringing the
players perspective
uh to a show that was new i mean we all
take
uh nfl pregame shows for granted now but
you were creating something
somewhat out of whole cloth back in 1975
brent yeah of course you know rich the
the big difference was we were live
uh prior to the nfl today a patch summer
all
and jack whitaker actually taped the
pregame show for sunday
for cbs sunday on friday afternoon
before they would head out to uh to
various games and when bob wassler
and he invented the nfl today it was his
idea that
it should be live and not only that but
the the halftime
and the post game shows should be live
and
then he put together at first it was uh
it was me and irv and when he checked in
and suggested her if i was g
i couldn't believe it that i was going
to be reunited with uh
with my old friend from northwestern and
i looked forward to it a couple months
later
bob suggested phyllis george and uh
and we were all on board and we
rehearsed and uh
it honestly especially with irv it was
like we'd all been friends for a long
long time
and uh no problem a year later they
added um
added jimmy the greek to the mixture
um and i you know we were all
you know the greek and fellows had had
their moments
uh simply because that stemmed from
phyllis's marriage to uh
john y brown who had been the governor
of kentucky and was the founder of kfc
and the greek
had done some pr work and he thought
he'd been shortchanged when uh
when the company went public but
whatever you know that's
small time gossip it was um it was great
you know we were listen i was a total
unknown and at that time
at that time many broadcasters who had
what i want to call difficult or long
last names
changed their name um jim mckay for
example
uh his real name was mcmanus
but i i said no i'll just stick with
muss burger i wrote with it
and we will go forward so so it was a
time of great excitement for me uh
to be involved with this particular show
but as i look back i was blessed
with with her phyllis and uh
and even the greek and bob wessler made
a
great great hiring decision i think the
key to a studio show with
multiple personalities is the chemistry
and it is not something
you can make up uh it just
it happens in and what happens is the
audience
the audience senses it without really
thinking about it
and then they become comfortable and uh
the nfl today had had great radiant
success and
of course with irvine you know the one
point i want to make about her just such
a gentleman
we we all know that and everybody like
but i'm going to tell you rich
he was a terrific football player um
i know seven or eight years with the
eagles and then three i think it was
with the rams but
he went to a couple of pro bowls he was
he was an outstanding defensive back
uh later coached briefly with the eagles
before turning turning to broadcasting
but i
i don't want to overlook what how good
an athlete
uh erv was he was a hurdler sprinter
when he came out of hammond
he'd been a track star from a huge
family i'd
10 or 11 other children in that family
as i recall
of course he needed the scholarship uh
to get to college
and um in those days you had to work
you do small jobs around the school and
and that gave you some income which are
needed to pay for incidentals as time
time went on i would see him i would say
oh probably once a week
when he was doing his job we'd stop and
talk and he knew i loved sports and i
was over at the uh
the student newspaper and uh but i
it it's one of those things that
you know you you don't think about it at
the time now looking back on it we know
that our cross was the first
african-american
uh to host a sports studio show and and
phyllis was the first woman
but honestly uh in that day we
we didn't even talk about i honestly
didn't even think about it to tell you
the truth out in hindsight we look back
and we see the evolution and the number
of
african-americans we have now hosting
the various networks and we have so many
more women
who are involved and but we never
thought of
i can't remember one discussion with her
about race we just we were friends
um you know he he deserved the position
he was my go-to guy when i needed
the the one thing about irv if things
were you know backing up on me
with all the live fire that we had i
could i could throw
any question to him about football and i
knew that herb
would be able to handle it in some way
why while i would regroup and
get the next command from the production
truck
and i love that brent just the fact that
you know
because i do recall i do recall his
quiet
cool demeanor that there was
really very rarely a voice raised
and a certain respect that his voice and
his demeanor commanded just when he
opened his mouth and that you know
it was a a a wonderful
ad or or wonderful presence
to a mix that sometimes could spin a
little bit the other way
right no absolutely you know no question
uh you know the greek would stir things
up but we always had the calmness of
a river cross to uh to rely on
are going forward and uh you know after
he left broadcasting
a lot of people probably don't realize
he became athletic director at idaho
state
and later at mcallister in saint paul so
uh yeah just uh just such such a nice
nice to always inform rich i cannot
remember
one broadcast that he uh
wasn't able to make it i think irv was
there for everyone
of the nfl today's as i recall he just
he never took a leave of absence for
anything and
he loved the nfl there was there was no
doubt about it i mean he
he really uh enjoyed everything
everything about the league and he knew
it was growing at the time and
um he would come in and watch the games
when we weren't on the air we would
watch him together in the
cbs studio and he was always always
interested in what was going on
brett mussberger here uh on the rich
eisen show um
i would be remiss if i didn't ask you a
quick question about the raiders
um whose games you broadcast uh
on the radio and certainly for rich
eisenhower radio affiliate raider nation
radio
um in las vegas nevada um
that uh the starting quarterback for the
raiders in 2021 taking the first snap
would be
you want to fill in that blank derrick
car car
no car no question uh i in fact
i have to tell you that i'm a little
disappointed
by the continuing chatter about the
raiders
uh you know deshaun watson's name of
course came up and it's
possible he'd be moving on uh from
houston
uh derrick carr's offense was more
productive
than deshawn watson now i'm not saying
that derek carr is a better prospect i'm
not saying that
but people need to look at what derek
accomplished
last year uh with the eight wins the
the problem that they lost eight games
was never on derek carr
is completely on the raider defense
and had that defense played better
especially in a couple of games that
come
immediately to my mind they would have
been in the playoffs i'm not
sure that they would have been able to
advance out of the wild card round
but derek carr was a playoff quarterback
last year and if if they wish to make a
move
um it would be in the backup in the
backup spot
bridge it's not it it doesn't make any
sense at all for the raiders
to spend a lot of what's going to be a
reduced salary cap
or something else on a on a new
quarterback and i'm a little
disappointed in the local press
in las vegas and not in not
really supporting him and what he was
able to uh
to accomplish uh last year with his team
the problem with the raiders is on the
defensive
side of the ball they have a new
administration new coaching staff
over there but they have misfired on
their
draft choices and they have misfired on
their free agent signings
and they need to correct that uh going
forward now
they were able to split with the chiefs
and the truth is
if they were able to play defense last
year they would have swept the chief
right then that the reason three mahomes
takes over one time
out they can't stop them uh they
couldn't stop
the miami dolphins with a horrendous
penalty
uh coming down the stretch oh gosh derek
out of my head he had him ahead in both
those games he did his job
well i mean i i guess maybe the reason
why
carr is being discussed is because that
you know has happened in the past even
though
carr had a terrific season that we're
seeing no sacred cows in the
in the nfl across the landscape here um
and because i you know i've i've pegged
it as the tom brady effect that every
team has seen that they could be
one player away and um obviously there's
only one brady but if you do get the
right quarterback in
maybe you upgrade and uh or you're
you're a veteran quarterback like
russell wilson or
aaron rodgers and you're seeing what
just happened with brady after staying
in one spot all this time that
maybe you're wondering that for you
something better can be had somewhere
else after all
i mean it's just as amazing what i'm
saying i'm wondering if you can compare
it to anything
uh in an off season in well in in
brady's case rich uh
he performed more like a general manager
quarterback
every point every point scored
by the buccaneers in a super bowl win
right by a player who was not there
the previous season and brady had a hand
in bringing three of them all the
touchdown scores in
the gronk obviously he comes back
because brady's there
antonio brown who had played briefly
he comes back because he even stayed at
brady's house for a time
up in new england and as i read
brady was one who called leonard
fournette
uh when he was on the street so so brady
did a lot more than just play
quarterback
and now it has come out that during the
weekend the build-up
he actually texted every one of his
teammates
and guaranteed that they would win the
game he was far
more than just an ordinary quarterback
signed by the buccaneers
and congratulations to him he obviously
want to accomplish what peyton manning
did with the denver broncos
and he did it um what what's interesting
to me
is all the gossip now deshaun watts is
not gossip that's that's confirmed we
know that
but as far as i can tell a lot of the
russell wilson chatter
uh is coming from an agent and not
russell i've known russell wilson for a
long long time and he's a really
really solid guy and uh
i can't believe that he's causing the
organization internal problems he may
have been unhappy
with some of the free agent signings in
the offensive line in particular
but i would be very very surprised if
the seahawks are shopping
russell wilson right now and i think
that aaron rodgers
aaron rodgers is a different kind of cat
uh
he he he likes his own attention and his
name was thrown out there
uh but i think that the two quarterbacks
i think that have been confirmed
obviously they shall watch obviously
houston has to make a decision down
there
and it sounds to me like the carolina
panthers
and the chicago bears so i make it three
now it's definitely shopping for a
quarterback i can't get a good read on
sam darnold in the jets i suppose if
if watson was shipped to the jets they
could send donald down
along with that second pick in the draft
and go from there but you know at that
time of season
it's it's the silly season as we call it
have called for a long time in baseball
to go back and look
every year at the rumors especially
about the quarterbacks uh there are
going to be some out there and i
and and of course the rams and the lions
kicking things off with their big trade
i think that helped move the move the
narrative along but as far as i'm
concerned
and i watch i've watched for three years
and
and i don't get this criticism of derek
carr uh
is he a hall of famer no maybe not but
he's a winning quarterback you you don't
have to worry about that spot but the
raiders have to worry
about the defensive personnel brent uh
i really cherish the time once again um
my condolence on the loss of your friend
and long-time colleague
in irv cross um and before i let you go
you you mentioned early in your career
that you were considering
shortening your name do you remember the
names that you were kicking around i
would have used my middle name woody
my mother's maiden name so brent woody
would have been
you're looking live with brent woody
yeah that would have been it lad
i think you'd made the right choice
brian
[Applause]
smart move brent yes thanks guys
thank you
the best brent woody doesn't uh
ow doesn't hit as much brent woody
no no but you know
the look you you gave you didn't
remember you didn't know that jim mckay
was jim mcmanus i had no idea
and the cbs sports president exactly
is is jim mccain's son i know that huh
no you didn't know that i didn't it's
okay you can admit you don't know
everything about
the industry it's okay i don't know
everything but yeah
how about that brentwoody everybody not
as good
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here